thanks for joining us on this day after
Thanksgiving and now it's time for the
fastest Thanksgiving recap Black Friday
chaos Thanksgiving protests and more but
first up all of you at home are probably
nursing your turkey hangover right now
and we hope you had a great holiday with
your friends and family but we're gonna
go take it around the table to see how
the five celebrated let's start with you
Greg well it was quite possibly one of
the greatest Thanksgivings I've ever had
you know I only have celebrities as
friends because they they make the best
friends so I can't show any real
pictures of what we did because they'd
be upset it's very George but here's to
my first picture I watched a lot of Fox
only when Leland bitter Todd because his
hair is amazing if you look at that hair
it's almost like a just a black helmet
best hair in the business the best hair
and then I had to guess I had this fella
came over later we actually we it wasn't
green when he got there but by the end
of the night he was green then this guy
showed up right here I landed on my roof
brought him in beautiful yeah quite
beautiful and then this woman just
happened the corner I have no idea who
she is not really she is and then later
do we have this this is my collection of
rubber duckies because of Thanksgiving I
just have one long bubble bath well
Italy finally I was able to program my
Roomba to deliver my boos glass of
chardonnay which I'm not a big fan of
and that's not even in Internet
Chardonnay I know but what my Roomba
doesn't know the Nazi wine color or
anything you know the Chardonnay very
masculine Gillian what Greg you need to
return that room I'm fired so my family
is celebrating on Saturday this year
okay that's tomorrow so we haven't
celebrated Thanksgiving it so instead I
thought I would bring you some photos of
Olivia and her best this is Olivia two
years ago pre turkey she's looking
lovingly this is last year right before
the turkey so we've got before and after
okay it's the after from two years ago
they are going after Dana's uh
let's eat and then this this is Olivia
now looking forward to Christmas she's
really excited that's her boyfriend's oh
very oh I didn't know I even sent that
one very cute
okay mm-hmm and you Jessica and welcome
to the five oh thank you
very excited to be here that's your
first time it is not don't screw it up
thank you Greg that's super helpful so
I'm from New York City so I was at home
with my family my sister and my new
brother-in-law got back from their
honeymoon the night before so we talked
a lot about their trip but we were just
at home I only have a couple shots we're
not a massive photo family so want to
share this one this is my mother and my
sisters Goldendoodle who have the same
hair oh okay you usually tell them apart
but the human what taller one is her and
then of my dad who's an amazing cook
went to cooking school makes his own
bread so I wanted to show everyone that
that is going on at a Tarlov HQ very
needy individual um gift so watch the
Thanksgiving Day Parade you know with
family and friends and that was very
nice cuz you didn't see the whole thing
right from where I was and then we had
wonderful Thanksgiving dinner with my
son and his father and his parents
awareness grandparents and was super fun
we had the best time and my friend and
came so roped her into the whole thing
that's great no pictures no no pictures
right you're like me I would reveal my
location exactly and all the celebrity
all the same restaurant I was with my
family and my mother when I got there
gave me a make America green again
bumper sticker and talked a lot about
Gutfeld as a matter if that's what she
says your name is Gutfeld ah she doesn't
know how to pronounce her name and she
did not like how Trump did the turkey
pardon
she's so that was insensitive because he
joked about revoking the Obama turkey
pardon that was mean and nasty
a lot of things about to say about Al
Franken I promised I would not share
with all right next Black Friday madness
is officially in full swing on this the
busiest shopping day of the year some
frantic bargain hunters are coming to
blows over the best deals check out
these two brawls it happened earlier now
I don't know if you guys can see this at
home but I sustained a little black
friday injury here on my head wrestling
a television away from an angry father
at Best Buy and we have a little
band-aid so I'm okay is that true
storage if you have it not a three story
story it's much more embarrassing than
that that I'm not also crazy this is the
this is if you ever want to argue
against capitalism show those pictures
because it's just like in 99% of these
people don't even want that product it's
because what happens is you in this out
you don't want the product so they had
they they lower the price so you decide
maybe you do want it but you really
don't want it or else you would have
already purchased it you wouldn't have
wait and then get in and then fight by
the way the worst part about this is is
if every everyday should be black I
don't know why it has to be Black Friday
I think that's weird I think they we
should replace all holiday music with
goth music holiday goth music Sisters of
Mercy Peter Murphy do it let's just make
everyday black okay that's why you're
not in charge what this is why that's
not this is yes it's true but don't they
have like cyber monday and can't you get
all these same deals all right the truth
are you ready yes bring it okay every
day from today until January 1st is
going to be the same there will be
massive sales
I think Black Friday is dead it's off
you heard it here first on the five okay
Friday is dead it's all a lie from here
going forward
everything is massively discounted okay
this is fake
that's near the segment of speaking news
okay well makes sense that I'm hosting
it Jessica
you would not be caught dead in one of
these department stores I can imagine no
I absolutely was loved oh I thought you
meant that fantastic dress like that no
I love going into Best Buy and remember
running around I did not pick up a TV
today but they now hook you with the
emails early so we're days right oh it's
starting this is early Black Friday it's
already 90% off and then 90% off on top
of the 90% off and and all of that so I
did some online shopping but no
in-person brawling and Kimberly has
everything money can buy so she doesn't
need to do any shopping on Black Friday
well you know it's just like any other
day of the year it's kind of like aren't
there always good deals are free
shipping and buses so far I think
purchase was somehow my son put it in
the cart the Nintendo switch thing is
hard you've already made okay keep on
coming if you have to wait for this for
Christmas and then two bathing suits
maybe this is a good thing because if
technology is eliminating our ability to
fight that this is a good thing to
remind us how to fight that this is
important because we're too busy at home
ordering things it's good one day of the
year to go out and fight to the death
get back to a rule you get to our roots
I think you have no patience for that no
no I hide under a bed spritzer heavily
discounted bed and finally yesterday was
Thanksgiving but that didn't stop some
football players from continuing to be
anti-american Colin Kaepernick spent the
holiday at the annual on Thanksgiving
Day protest on Alcatraz Island
but the former 49ers quarterback made a
surprise appearance at the event which
commemorates the 19 month occupation of
the notorious prison by Native American
activists from 1969 to 71 you've been
out to Alcatraz I know and they actually
do this every year yeah well I mean you
know but leave it to Colin Kaepernick to
make it about himself you like try to
ruin Thanksgiving he's like the new
Grinch that stole Thanksgiving
now he's gonna probably move on to
Christmas help ruin the NFL drove the
ratings down also the profits I mean wow
when you see him coming just run the
other way that's right
like Bad News Bears there you go I don't
know if I'd run the other way per se I
do think this is unless he was throwing
you the ball that's right
I would not also be able to catch that
if he was throwing me the ball I I think
this is an exceptionally bad PR move for
Colin Kaepernick after he got the GQ
Citizen of the Year award I I thought it
was a great opportunity to I guess be
more useful to people on both sides to
make them understand what the kneeling
is actually about and what that all
stands for and also to be respectful of
American traditions and things that are
of value to a lot of people and so I
didn't think this was a great thing
though I also didn't know that it
happened every year so that's a bonus
that I learned something new there we go
he's clearly going all-in Julian well
here's the problem I think if you want
to fight and try and give a voice to
Native American Indian activists that's
fine but you can't fight everything all
at once in one year you can't fight the
flag and the national anthem and thanks
get a conundrum self - he's spreading
himself too thin
he's a mr. Potatohead social justice
warrior it just changes SOP for Native
Americans - but you it the real sin is
he chose Alcatraz over alcohol
Thanksgivings about alcohol but you know
where two miserable Thanksgiving mmm and
the reason why he would did an interview
he's enraged that Donald Trump has not
responded to his angry rap and therein
lies a solution
if you do not respond to this if Colin
Kapernick will fade into a certain
obscurity the more that we talk about it
the more he gets out of this
so like Eminem is so upset because Trump
will not even acknowledge that rap and
that is the best kind but that's a
that's kind of revenge and it shows that
he wanted the attention right that was
jealous of levar balls
he's like what about me I'm over here
bar ball for praising it set well I mean
I need to learn how to tweet that's
right yeah this bar balls got away
Democrat candidate he's like I want to
thank the president either okay what
about me all right coming up